bonjour aujourd'hui 13 novembre nouvelle
édition de votre journal de fin de
semaine voici lé titre le skipper
versaillais tanguy de lamotte a bouclé
hier soir la 12e édition de la transat
jacques vabre avec sa coéquipière
samantha davies grâce au soutien des
internautes laventure permettra à
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque et d'opérer
vingtaine d'enfants au 1er janvier 2016
si maison départementale des yvelines
vont être créés pour renforcer la
proximité du département auprès des
populations nous en parlerons un plateau
avec ghislain fournier laisser le vice
président délégué à la nouvelle
organisation territoriale et comme
chaque vendredi et retour sur les
principaux sujets que nous avons traité
cette semaine du test de la première
voiture autonome à versailles aux
commémorations du 11 novembre
les deux nouvelles mesures autour du
temps de travail doivent entrer en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2016 pour les
agents de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines la durée légale pour
les fonctionnaires s'appliquera mettant
fin à une série d' avantages concédés
depuis une quarantaine d'années se sont
ainsi par exemple 13 jours de congés par
an qui vont être supprimés après l'échec
des négociations en début de semaine la
grève a été votée par l'intersyndicale
cfdt cgt pour ce vendredi 13 nous vous
l'avions annoncé déjà hier un
rassemblement s'est tenu devant le siège
de l'agglomération vous envoyer les
images et si aucun accord n'est possible
les agents veulent durcir le ton du côté
de l'agglomération on évoque la
nécessité de se mettre en conformité
avec la loi écoutez directeur général
des services dominique ceaux saint-alban
donc la casse qui a engagé depuis le
mois de septembre
la question de la révision de son temps
de travail pour coller au cadre légal
qui veut que l'ensemble des salariés de
france et de navarre travail à temps
plein à 1607 heures par an aujourd'hui
les salariés de la casse qui travaillent
en moyenne 1500 12 heures donc le sujet
que nous portons aujourd'hui est de
pouvoir au titre de l'exemplarité du
service public revenir à ce cadre légal
le dialogue est encore ouvert il n'a
jamais été interrompues michel laugier
je voulais dit tout à l'heure a souhaité
véritablement que nous ayons un très
grand nombre de réunions avec les
représentants du personnel
la date du 1er janvier arrive maintenant
il faut véritablement que l'on aille à
l'accord avec détermination avec envie
en préservant bien entendu la souplesse
de travail en permettant aux
collaborateurs de bien articuler leur
vie personnelle avec les contraintes du
service public mais le sujet il est là
nous sommes ouverts à cette négociation
nous le restons et je doute pas que nous
parviendrons à un accord pour payer par
fanny bordillon la grève menée
aujourd'hui et est reconductible nous
verrons dans les prochains jours comment
les agents souhaitent réagir un mot de
politique à présent avec cette prise de
position de benoît hamon le député des
yvelines socialiste candidat aux
régionales en ile-de-france l'assemblée
nationale vient d'adopter son amendement
pour que la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines conserve le
dispositif de pondération fiscal dont
elle bénéficie concrètement cela
signifie que la contribution due par 50
ans ne sera pas multiplié par six elle
restera d'un peu moins de 2 millions
d'euros permettant ainsi de préserver
les finances
et puisque j'ai évoqué brièvement les
régionales sachez que lutte ouvrière
occupe le terrain à moins d'un mois du
scrutin avec un meeting régional pour la
liste ile de france à paris avec un
nathalie arthaud ce vendredi 13 novembre
à 20h30 à la mutualité à paris puis
demain samedi avec une réunion publique
à 18 heures avec thierry gonot c'est la
tête de liste yvelines et ce sera à
mantes la jolie
ils sont arrivés hier soir le skipper
versaillais tanguy de lamotte et sa
coéquipière samantha davies qui termine
5e de la transat jacques vabre qui relie
la france au brésil
un beau succès sportif après 18 jours de
course est aussi un formidable espoir
sur le plan de la solidarité le seul et
qui page mixte de la catégorie imoca sur
leur monocoque initiative coeur va
permettre de sauver une vingtaine
d'enfants tout au long de la course et
pour chaque clic et partage sur leur
page facebook
quelques euros ont été reversés à
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque dont le but est de faire venir
en france des enfants malades pour qu'il
soit opéré royal royal super content
d'être là dur de vie être justement donc
c'est pour ça qu'on est super content et
jusqu'au bout on ya cru jusqu'au bout on
s'est battu le duo a vachement bien
fonctionné l'équipe avec sam a été
génial et et on a battu on a été au
dessus des objectifs qu'on s'était fixés
quoi donc que pour ce qui est des
objectifs solides herbe a atteint 20
enfants ce qui était le double de ce
qu'on avait fixé au départ donc voilà ça
c'est top mais le début de l'aventuré en
2012 d'initiative coeur ce sont au total
plus de 50 enfants qui ont déjà été
opérées on quitte le brésil pour revenir
dans les yvelines quelques images à
présent de l'intégration hier deux à
cinq enfants de maurepas aux clubs coup
de pouce coup de pouce c'est une
association qui en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale permet à chaque
élève depuis 20 ans à travers la france
d'accéder à un parcours de réussite
scolaire grâce à une aide personnalisée
concrètement des animateurs vont aider
les enfants en dehors des heures de
cours avec le relais des parents le
climat en question jusqu'au 12 décembre
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin propose un mois
d'activités conférences expositions
projections autour du climat
samedi dernier déjà la médiathèque du
petit canal accueillait un serious game
un jeu d'immersion ou les décisions du
joueur impact à nos actions sur
l'environnement mélanie poker depuis
plus d'un siècle nous utilisons les
ressources énergétiques sans se
préoccuper de leur quantité direction
l'année 2020 nous pourrions être dans
une impasse
la mission de ces enfants remonter le
temps là il s'agit d'aider le maire à
choisir une source d'énergie durable
tout à l'heure on a parlé d
nrj on a dit qu'elle pouvait être
fossiles qu'est ce que les énergies
fossiles sont durables non serious game
est particulièrement
focalisée autour des enjeux des
problématiques autour de l'énergie donc
lié à ce pillage de l'énergie les
énergies fossiles et énergies
renouvelables de la sobriété énergétique
et de l'efficacité énergétique
accompagné de trois conseillers
environnemental social et économique
ces jeunes ont dû notamment et des
benjamins organiser ses vacances ou
olivier à reconstruire un village on a
c'est une ville
enfin en arrêt 5 enfin on a renouvelé la
ville on a amélioré on a mis des
panneaux solaires pour ligne pour les
connaissons un pour l'énergie économiser
l'électricité parce que je sais que j'ai
des fois quand je sors de ma chambre
j'ai su bien ali mais eux sont parvenus
à rendre la terre plus durable et
vivable si vous voulez vous aussi tenter
de protéger la planète
le serious game peut se jouer en ligne
on en vient à l'invité de ce vendredi je
reçois ghislain fournier conseiller
départemental des yvelines responsable
de la nouvelle organisation territoriale
bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau
1er janvier 2016 si maison
départementale des yvelines vont être
créés pour renforcer la proximité du
département auprès des populations
à quoi cela va servir tout simplement
alors ça va servir à rendre un meilleur
service à la fois aux usagers mais
surtout aux maires et aux intercours on
est dans quel contexte on est dans un
contexte clairement de réorganisation
parce que nous avons nos contexte
législatif qui fait que nous sommes dans
la création des grandes
intercommunalités parce que le découpage
de ces six maisons du département des
maisons des portions calais ont calé sur
les galets algérien la future intercos
hurler future agglo officielle au 1er
janvier qui seront officielles au 1er
janvier
et donc ça forcément redéfini les
politiques d'aménagement et
d'intervention du conseil départemental
sur notre territoire
et puis nous sommes aussi dans une dans
un contexte de baisse forte des
dotations de l'état
absolument sans précédent pour le
conseil départemental divine ce qui nous
amène forcément à repenser l'action
publique et à proposer des créations de
ces maisons départementales vous l'avez
dit si maison départementale 4 ans
territoires urbains et 2
territoire on y fera quoi danser mais
alors on y fera quoi y aura quatre
grands pôles
il y aura tout d'abord un pôle santé
dans lequel y aura toutes les actions de
pmi de planification familiale
toutes les actions de santé publique
avec la rs nous aurons également un pôle
autonomie tout ce qui concerne personnes
handicapées personnes âgées avec les
politiques da par aida pch nous aurons
le pôle social qui concernera
l'accompagnement du public fragile
mission fondamentale de l'action sociale
du conseil départemental avec
l'ouverture notamment des droits au rsa
l'aide sociale à l'enfance également et
puis un dernier paul qui est le pôle de
développement local dans lequel on y
mettra toutes les politiques d'insertion
de retour à l'emploi du du public qui
est en recherche et surtout tous qui
aménagement du territoire
ça doit être l'interface des intercoms
et des mères quand ils viennent demander
de l'aide
et surtout quand ils viennent demander
de participer aux politiques
départementales vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure la baisse des dotations il ya
quelques mois quelques années auparavant
on évoquait même la disparition des
départements pour faire des économies
la création de ces maisons
départementales c'est pas paradoxal ça
va pas coûter plus cher
non ça va pas coûter plus cher et
l'objectif si vous voulez comme je les
dis c'est d'envisager l'avenir en se
calant sur le périmètre des intercoms et
c'est aussi donner une réactivité accrue
aux interlocuteurs que sont les maires
et les présidents d'interco et puis
pouvoir répondre spécifiquement aux
besoins particuliers des territoires qui
ont tous leurs spécificités
donc ce n'est pas une strate
supplémentaire entre les intercoms les
départements c'est pas une stat
supplémentaires complète je dirais que
c'est complémentaire
c'est en ça s'apparente à de la
déconcentration c'est à dire que on va
rendre le service au plus près des
usagers et tout ça aura un coût un
courant l'organisation sera un coup
globalement le coup il est maîtrisé
puisque
le patrimoine immobilier pour la plupart
ils existent déjà
il y aura du déplacement de personnel
dans quelle organisation plus plus mais
c'est une vaste réorganisation plus
globale dont l'objectif est aussi
d'optimiser et de rationaliser les
dépenses pour le conseil départemental
la mise en place et le 1er janvier ce
que vous êtes prêts pour ça est ce que
ensuite il y aura aussi un bilan qui
sera fait pour juger de la pertinence de
ces maisons tout à fait alors
aujourd'hui c'est six maisons
départementales il y en a déjà qui
fonctionne il y en a dont les équipes
sont toutes constituées en tout cas il y
en a qui fonctionne sur les lieux qui
sont programmés d'autres sur des lieux
mais vraisemblablement vont bouger sur
les six territoires les lieux sont
déterminés les villes sont déterminés
simplement elles ne sont pas toutes
encore en action sur sur les lieux
puisque pour des problèmes immobiliers
il ya encore des ajustements à faire et
des transferts immobilier a réalisé
parmi les différences ajustements il ya
aussi cette question des pmi sc cette
protection maternelle et infantile qui
est réorganisée dans le cadre de ce
dispositif s'est fait en parallèle en
fait tout simplement certains maires
s'inquiètent de voir disparaître leur
pmi on a déjà parlé sur ce plateau vous
êtes d'ailleurs déjà exprimé ce soit les
maires de lui en cours de la verrière
par exemple qui verrait disparaître lors
leur pmi sur leur commune
il ya une nouvelle mobilisation qui est
prévu d'ailleurs demain devant les
locaux du conseil départemental samedi
matin à versailles
vous réagissez comme ans où on est la
discussion et c'est ce qu'on a
l'impression que là que chacun comme
c'est pour sur ses positions
non alors on avance alors sur la
réorganisation globale vous l'avez dit
l'objectif d'arriver à une vingtaine de
pmi mais qu'ils soient ouvertes au
public en permanence qu'ils soient des
vrais lieux d'accueil qu'ils soient des
vrais lieux où on a une consultation à
la fois de médecins et d depuis hier
cinq jours sur sept
qu'ils puissent être éventuellement
ouverte en soirée quand les besoins des
populations le nécessitent donc des
vrais lieux lisible professionnels et
permettant un meilleur accueil de la
population par rapport à ce qui existe
aujourd'hui où 60% des permis ne sont
ouverts que deux après midi par semaine
des discussions encore rouge alors bien
sûr que les discussions et vous parliez
vous parliez de guyancourt ont géré reçu
j'ai reçu le maire il nous a fait des
nouvelles propositions
il s'avère que j'ai appris il nous a
appris qu'il allait devoir fermer une
école à guyancourt l'école coton et qui
s'avère être un lieu tout à fait
judicieux pour installer
vraisemblablement et même certainement
la future pmi de billancourt
donc c'est celui là qui sera choisi pour
la pmi
il me met néanmoins il ya toujours une
mobilisation demain je lui apprends en
tout cas que ce choix vient d'être fait
nous l'avons fait en concertation avec
la conseillère générale laurence rochus
qui s'est beaucoup mobilisé sur le sujet
et aujourd'hui ce choix nous paraît très
pertinent et lui sur le secteur de
montigny devis en cours justement au
conseil départemental ont globalement
dans le cadre de cette réorganisation
puisque vous êtes en charge pour le
conseil départemental de cette nouvelle
organisation territoriale est ce qu'il
ya d'autres dossiers d'autres priorités
qui ont se mettre en place sur les
écouter vous avez en effet les maisons
départementales
vous avez les pmi et vous avez les
secteurs d'action sociale sur lesquels
nous allons travailler pour trouver des
lieux les plus pertinents possibles et
les plus en adéquation avec les besoins
de la population tout ça dans un
contexte de baisse des dotations et il
sa limite votre action très fort très
forte baisse des dotations historique
pour lever la part de l'hymne de la part
de l'état évidemment ça nécessite de
notre part beaucoup d'imagination
merci à julien fournier d'être passé sur
le plateau pour nous faire part de cette
réorganisation territoriale vous l'avez
compris concernant les pm il y ait
mobilisation mais le dialogue qui se
poursuit avec des solutions qui sont à
l'étude et puis et c'est maison
départementale des yvelines au 1er
janvier 2016 merci à vous nous passons
la seconde partie de cette édition du
vendredi de votre journal
comme chaque vendredi
retour sur l'actualité de la semaine
voici le zapping et le zapping de leur
faune locale cela fait un an et demi
qu'ils manifestent demain vendredi 13
les médecins libéraux vous frapper un
grand coup contre la loi santé de
marisol touraine
près de 90 % d'entre eux devraient
fermer leurs cabinets ils ont nommé leur
mouvement le black friday
à première vue rien de très futuriste
c'est à l'intérieur que cette voiture
bi-mode cache ses innovations caméras
capteurs équipements électroniques et
ordinateurs dans le coffre permettent à
ce véhicule se conduire tout seul
partout autour d'elle si l'admission à
360° tout autour de la voiture à la pad
englobant une fois que je perds sur mon
environnement j'ai besoin de savoir
je suis si les techniques de
localisation et une bo à versailles
c'est ce compte est surtout c'est
dérisoire
trouvez moi une facture d'un hélicoptère
c'est dommage c'est que ça donne un peu
de deux côtés négatifs sur
l'agglomération qui est une vraie
réussite
et quand on veut faire le bilan d'une
entreprise on revient pas que son passif
parce que ça je connais aucune société
qui regardent que son passif va bien il
faut regarder aussi l'actif 15 novembre
à 15 heures à la salle de la torah
voisins bretons ne vous serait présente
journaliste 2014 vous quittez le burundi
après avoir dénoncé les actes
antidémocratiques du président et
aujourd'hui vous dites que la situation
est critique nombre de la société civile
aux journalistes beaucoup ont choisi le
chemin de l'exil
c'était la mort on a un régime du
président justement le président que
veut garder son mandat qui est anti
constitutionnelle qui a été donné c'est
pâques est dénoncée par les actrices
société civile des journalistes et du
coudray attendant la mort
sept et plus particulièrement ce jour
celui des anciens élèves du lycée hoche
nombreux à grimper au cours du premier
conflit mondial
380 nom résonne entre les murs du lycée
hoche ce matin à versailles une matinée
pour se souvenir et rendre hommage aux
anciens élèves tombés au champ d'honneur
une cérémonie qui n'avait pas eu lieu
depuis 20 ans raviver aujourd'hui grâce
aux élèves de l'établissement
le 12 novembre 2014 voici tout juste un
an le robot fils a été transportée par
la sonde européenne rosetta se posait
sur la comète souris une réussite à
laquelle l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines s'associent
nous revenons sur cet événement
historique le club de football de
trappes est en deuil l'attaquant de
l'équipe senior samba sissoko 20 ans
l'un des meilleurs joueurs du
championnat de promotion d'honneur est
décédé dans un accident de la route dans
la nuit de samedi à dimanche dans la
zone d'activités de trappes un mot de la
programmation à présent de nos confrères
de radio sensations nicolas kirillovitch
reçoit pour son hebdo politique dimanche
à 18 heures jean michel fourgous et
sandrine grand gambe le premier vice
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint-quentin des
républicains et la responsable de
l'opposition socialiste les deux élus et
vont échanger débattre sur les audits et
puis ces accusations de mauvaise gestion
dont font l'objet
l'ancienne équipe écoutez un extrait
pourquoi est ce qu'on trouve des ordres
de mission au lieu de partir en
hélicoptère un ordre de mission c'est un
nombre de missions et signé par le
président me dit que c'est un faux
menant bah voyons un ordre de mission
signé par le président a dressé un voile
et céramiste président sambi en grande-
motte c'est de l'info mais enfin non
mais si c'est ça la dialectique
socialiste c'est que vous n'assumez
jamais vos heures verra remettre le pays
dans une situation de la démocratie
c'est quand même temps qu'est ce que
vous dites de toutes ces dépenses
déjà moi je veux voir les ordres de
paiement qui est ce que l'agglomération
à payer les déplacements en hélicoptère
l'agglomération n'a pas payé je vous
avais ces informations là par exemple
vous donnez de certains quoi il ya un
ordre de mission c'est de justesse que
vous avez un ordre de paiement
est-ce que vous allez est-ce que cet
ordre de mission est un fort et là je
vous dis est ce que vous avez en normes
non j'ai pas non plus le le contrôle de
l'hélicoptère voyez j'ai pas de route
la pièce d'un conte et le contrôle des
derniers de
annoncer quelque chose de très grave
module d de lille comme ça oubliez pas
dans les audits parce qu'en fait le
problème qui s'est passé décision
politique donne pas suite à écouter sur
radio sensations dimanche soir retrouver
sur le compte youtube de la station
quant à nous le journal va revenir lundi
avec florane parfait il sera question au
cours de la semaine de la soirée des
entrepreneurs organisé par la communauté
d'agglomération le thème la france qui
innovent dans un monde qui bouge
olivier dassault président du conseil de
surveillance du groupe industriel marcel
dassault ou encore guillaume sarkozy
délégué général de malakoff médéric
seront présents et cette soirée sera
retransmise sur notre antenne donc mardi
à partir de 18h30 juste après le journal
de la rédaction et puis également dans
le journal cette semaine le résumé
complet du festival du film documentaire
à 50 ans qui se déroule jusqu'au 15
novembre
expositions rencontres ateliers bien sûr
projection à travers toute
l'agglomération
le festival s'est ouvert hier soir jeudi
à l'ugc de montigny-le-bretonneux vous
le voyez on se quitte à présent pour ce
journal du vendredi avec du sport du
tennis de table le championnat
départemental des vétérans étaient
programmés mercredi dernier au gymnase
thierry gilardi des clayes-sous-bois au
total une centaine de participants entre
quarante et soixante dix ans les détails
avec michael et demi d'euros et william
l et je vous souhaite un excellent week
end
la passion pour le tennis de table n'a
pas d'âge pour la deuxième année
consécutive le championnat départemental
des vétérans une catégorie pour les
joueurs âgés de 40 à 70 ans était
organisé au gymnase thierry gilardi des
clayes-sous-bois objectif de cette
compétition déterminer le classement des
yvelines les meilleurs sont qualifiés
pour le championnat régional
le tennis de table est un sport qui
vieillit faut le dire donc à plus en
plus de vétérans mais des vétérans qui
joue depuis déjà un bon moment au niveau
de la pratique de ce sport et le niveau
reste assez intéressant puisque les
meilleurs vont se qualifier pour le
niveau régional et après le niveau
national au total 116 participants venus
de 23 clubs du département ont participé
à la compétition pour remporter la
victoire chaque joueur a sa technique le
joug emprise porte plume comme un
certain nombre de chinois c'est à dire
que je tiens ma raquette avec deux
doigts
c'est un petit peu particulier parce que
le jeu est très axé sur le coup droit
après effectivement chaque personne a
son propre jeu il ya des attaquants et
les défenseurs et à l'intérieur des
attaquants les défenseurs il ya aussi
des spécificités quoi c'est plutôt
la poussette et le contre à
voilà un peu le revers mais lâche un
petit café avec mon revers vous avez vu
la finale on a surtout beaucoup poussé
ont assez de se neutraliser mais voilà
mon jeu serra peut décider d'embêter
adversaires puisque de marquer des
points en attaquant très fort plusieurs
techniques mais l'objectif reste la
victoire sept joueurs sont montés sur la
plus haute marche du podium dans leur
catégorie respective
chez les hommes le gluant courtois
pascal piesset a brillé pendant la
compétition
le pongiste a raflé la mise dans la
catégorie des 50 59 ans